successful opinion magazines are often
launched by successful people
the new republic was co-founded by the
famous progressive intellectual walter
lipman
national review was launched by the
best-selling author william f buckley
reason on the other hand was the
brainchild of a 20 year old boston
university student
who wrote in one of his early editors
notes i drive a delivery van for a
living
lanny friedlander stapled together and
mailed out the first mimeographed issues
of reason
from a messy room in his mother's house
in brighton massachusetts
he would sell the fledgling magazine
just two years later and slowly fade
away
and yet lanny's blazing and influential
vision still lives on
visible in reason's lowercase sans-serif
logo its sympathy for outsiders and
dreamers
and in its hunch that technology more
than politics is the driving force of
human freedom
within a few years there's going to be
computers in in many homes and then
eventually most homes
that means that you can have
individualized news because you can just
say i only want news about
uh about spirit diagonal or i don't want
any news about spirit diagnose
friedlander believed in gathering
various strains of libertarianism under
one roof
for stimulating debate and was committed
to engaging with the best ideas of his
political adversaries
we would just discuss the structure of
society and what we can do
on in the areas that we agree upon
lanny's mix of startling visual
presentation
and contrarian writing created an almost
instant momentum
tantalizing early readers and
contributors alike with an infectious
sense of unimagined possibilities when
reason speaks of poverty racism the
draft the war
student power politics and other vital
issues
it shall be reasons not slogans it gives
for conclusions
proof not belligerent assertion logic
not legends coherence not contradictions
this is our promise this is the reason
for reason so who was this disheveled
visionary and why did he flame out so
fast
upon friedlander's death in 2011 reasons
nick gillespie wrote that he had started
thinking of lanny as libertarianism's
answer to sid barrett
the mad genius founder of pink floyd who
got something great started
and then couldn't or wouldn't live in
the world he did so much to create
in reality lanny friedlander was an
objectivist who believed in big tent
libertarianism
a student protester who reviled other
student protesters
an anti-war anti-draft activist who
volunteered for the navy
he was professionally charismatic and
personally introverted
an exacting truth seeker and unreliable
narrator
a systemic thinker and disorganized
coordinator
the printed format of this issue he
wrote does not represent a guarantee
that the next issue will also be
printed wired co-creator louis rossetto
who first encountered reason as an
undergrad at columbia university
said in 2011 that the publication was my
gateway to good design
yet when describing his own self
friedlander preferred the term writer
intellectual
that writing contained a breath rarely
seen among twenty-somethings of any era
friedlander argued persuasively that
pollutionist theft
and applied austrian economics to the
question of how the police would operate
in a free society
at turns theoretical and practical
pedantic and poetic his voice vibrated
with a visceral rage when touching on
the dehumanization of modern
institutions
whatever reason the parents might have
for leaving his children in the care of
the state
he snarled in a piece about public
schools it will not diminish their
intellectual death
nor mitigate their emotional torture as
fate would cruelly have it
friedlander spent much of the rest of
his life institutionalized and chained
to the dulling anchor of anti-psychotic
drugs a diagnosed schizophrenic under
the weary eye of the paternalistic state
but before his sad decline there was a
bracing boldness to venture somewhere
new starting with how lanny's magazine
would look
visual elements that decades later would
become fetish in art schools
were there from the very beginning lanny
was a fan of massimo vignelli so reason
had a perfect swiss grid very clean and
pure
lots of white space ragged right
helvetica type conceptual illustrations
rosetta recalled friedlander consumed
the latest cutting-edge books and
periodical graphic design from nearby
mit
press including mail order newsletters
and zines and of course
comic books reason as early as 1969
published some original panels by
legendary spider-man co-creator steve
ditko
reason was anti-establishment without
being part of the new establishment and
without being either crank left or kook
right rosetta recalled
and it had this bright shiny optimism
and unshakable faith in the triumph of
good ideas
in 1968 friedlander's writing confronted
the burning issues of the moment
violence war race relations campus
upheaval
with boldly counter-intuitive takes it
is the initiation or threat of
initiation of physical force
by the government that is the major
cause of violence in america
he wrote both jim crow and minimum wage
laws were unambiguous examples of racism
and the new left and george wallace had
more in common than either would ever
admit
lanny was an odd duck but always
striking he was a person of few words in
conversation and always seemed to be
somewhat detached or inward in his way
recalls mark fraser who as a high school
student helped with paste up and other
tasks at the magazine
while the libertarian movement was
blooming in new york city in the early
1970s
lanny was starting to wither declining
even to participate much when his
protege lewis rosetto
invited him to come around the offices
of outlook another influential if
short-lived libertarian publication
after that there's a period where he
just disappeared the wheels started
coming off more often the mental illness
that had plagued his mother
appeared to be derailing a promising
young career friedlander's final byline
in the magazine he created came in
october 1972
just shy of his 25th birthday what came
next were vague tales of trouble travels
in the south
frantic calls for money a drunk and
disorderly misdemeanor conviction in
miami in 1975.
somewhere within that flailing period
friedlander enlisted in the navy
only to be discharged shortly thereafter
on psychiatric grounds so complete was
friedlander's break from his reason
founding past
that even his own attorney didn't
believe his friend's old war stories
lanny was telling me that he was this
great graphic artist and he started a
magazine and everything and of course
i'm thinking this was just a psychosis
you know i was all incredulous
reinforcing that skepticism was the one
time that lanny got anxious about losing
his art portfolio
after a search the missing satchel was
discovered and just like in a beautiful
mind the art was like third grade murphy
says
it was basically gibberish back in 2008
when i was editing reason
i asked my wife who is a private
investigator to help track freelander
down
turns out he was in a veteran's home in
lowell massachusetts she inadvertently
got him on the phone
is that you she said yes he responded
she told him that reason wanted to
connect and asked if she could pass
along his number
after a long pause he declined sounding
shell-shocked and wounded though not
quite mad
we arranged to have the magazine and
related swag sent to him on a regular
basis
then in december 2010 recent science
correspondent ron bailey
got a handwritten letter in the mail in
response to an article about genomics
i think you should take your thinking
one step further and write about the
prospects for immortality in the
foreseeable future
wrote a mr lannie friedlander i also
wonder if magicians can reverse the
effects of old age
then came the kicker p.s i started
reason magazine in 1968.
lanny died of a heart attack the
following year at the age of 63. lanny
friedlander did more than just start
reason
he willed into being a demonstration
project that you don't need money and
other built-in advantages to launch a
worthwhile journal of opinion
he showed people who didn't even know it
yet that they were entrepreneurs
journalists futurists and even
libertarians that there was a different
way of thinking and being in the world
that one could be revolutionary even
while advocating the most modest
of policy gains before his productive
brain betrayed him
he was consumed with a question that
challenges all of us to this day
how do you make social change in a world
where there is no single right answer
how do we explore maximize and expand
all the avenues for making the world a
better place
not that theory isn't important but it
this seems to be a movement primarily of
of philosopher kings one person defined
the libertarian movement as 800 people
trading books
we had to change that one man can stop
the motor of the world
einrand wrote an atlas shrugged the
opposite is also true
one man can start the motor not just of
one world but of several
that in the end is the legacy of lanny
friedlander
you